I'm actually on a mission man you know I
don't even think comedy is my calling in
life I think I'm meant for something
greater like I had a vision the other
night it came to me I think my mission
in life is to help white people like
really I want to feel comfortable enough
to walk in your house unannounced at 3
o'clock in the morning just wake you up
and go come with me
my comics we don't do [ __ ] and we on the
road except stay in hotel room and watch
TV and I'm flipping through some of the
stations and I'm watching these programs
like Oprah and Phil and I'm seeing some
of y'all's kids is out of [ __ ]
control I really want to ask my people
I've always been curious why don't y'all
just beat your kids man be done whupped
a [ __ ] ass [ __ ] y'all give
y'all kids all kind of timeouts and
special places the [ __ ] is a special
place to a black child that's a coma
what is the specialty black kids or no
[ __ ] bout time out we nobody getting
knocked the [ __ ] out that's it my mother
used to slap the [ __ ] out of me in
public and I would look at people for
help but shut up
white people felt my pain she just strap
your child like people see black kids
get hit like hey get your [ __ ] together
likely we will beat other people's kids
if they [ __ ] up too bad like miss you
need to put this up your mother [ __ ]
put that [ __ ] down here's my website
evening home address call me I'll [ __ ]
him up in a damn you need you ain't got
to kill him just watch him turn red come
out you know what I found out growing up
totally shocked me white kids is just as
shocked to find out black kids don't
talk back to their parents as we are
with him talk back to theirs so you just
have a little buddy will come over my
house on the weekends alone eight we be
in my room playing video games normally
used to come in the room on us cussed me
out for no reason just scare the [ __ ]
out of both we'd be in the room playing
Mario Brothers she come kick open the
door like swatting we'd be on level
fours yeah
here he's how many times on I told you
to clean this [ __ ] room cut
that goddamn game off the clean his room
I come back this [ __ ] room
ain't clean I'm gonna take it in the
channel cord wrap it around your neck
and stick it in your ass dig I ain't
plan but you did say no threat mister
promise try me [ __ ]
try me my white friend would turn to me
offended like dude what the [ __ ] she
can't do that man this is your space
yeah she's violating your right to
privacy you should say something you
want me to go say something I'd be so
scared I saw it talking to him like a
slave for roots like yous gonna get me
in trouble I like you Nate I really do
my parents is good black folks that give
us a bit food that gives me sleep you
get away from around here with that
foolishness
go get from here
yeah
well oh my mother smack the [ __ ] out the
white boy he turned into me weird in the
world I grew up in my neighborhood we
didn't have a lot of diversity in my
neighborhood diversity is always
people's talking about it and we didn't
have it you know my neighborhood was
poor black poor white that was our
neighborhood you know so I didn't feel
in a white privilege I know some people
had it man you know I knew some other
[ __ ] with sweaters but I was two tank
tops in the winter okay and I just
didn't feel it you know I wish I'd have
had some white privilege go sign me up
but I didn't have it man there's just
poor black kids poor white kids man and
my poor black friends are always like
man look what you did to us and I'm like
dude do you think I would do all that
[ __ ] to y'all and then move right next
door
now we gonna split this plum or not dawg
we're in this together man it was hectic
sometimes fighting with black kids is
tough on if you ever fought a bunch of
black dudes but they win they win dude
yeah I got jumped one time after a
football game about five black dudes
only ever fought five black dudes that
night
[Music]
just imagine you're fighting five black
dudes right now close your eyes now how
many black dudes are you fighting as
many as your imagination can hold and
when white kids are horrible to man it
was just an impoverished just that's
what's going on man
and if you're a black guy and you feel
like that's it racially insensitive then
imagine you were fighting five white
dudes in a cloud like damn this cloud is
aggressive and accurate pride recently
if you guys seen that movie let me see
that it's about the first all-black swim
team and the difficulties they had to go
through being the first all-black swim
team I mention question how many of
those white people are evil movies are
they gonna make it's like it's all the
way down to swimming you know I'm
starting to run out of white guilt you
know
now let's take those movies they started
off unbelievable start off with roots
right white guilt was at an all-time
high I could barely even watch it I'm
like dude I got it my ancestors evil
okay please please turn the channel dude
please turn the channel
they still hit them [ __ ] turn the
channel this is gonna be on all week
Jesus Christ then the 80s it was like a
football movie then like Cuba Gooding
want to be like a scuba diver I remember
that [ __ ] and now it's all the way down
to swimming and I gotta admit I don't
think I give a [ __ ] I'm not trying to be
a dick it's a recreational activity plus
I've been in pools there's been black
people in the pool you know I never saw
any white guy like trying to like
[ __ ] like prevent people saying they
just like making this [ __ ] up and I'm
not being a dick here either okay just
to clarify you know I just wanted
anybody coming up to me after the show
ah you know I was banking it then you
[ __ ] said it I'm not saying that I
don't think people should be loud put on
some speedos and go for a dip I'm not
saying that [ __ ] I'm just saying these
movies like the characters aren't even
believable like they always have to have
like that though the over-the-top
uninhibited white racist character you
know you know that guy he's a guy like
he's supposed to represent all the white
evil you know he's like the dude they
always have like screaming during the
movie trailer they'll be like they were
the first all-black swim team
like a big vein in his forehead this
screaming [ __ ] look not even looking
around you know
dudas ridiculous real racism is quiet
it's subtle people look around first
make sure that you know they make sure
the coast is clear
there's disclaimers like dude you know
I'm not racist but these insert group
name followed by [ __ ] up conversation
right that's how it goes down that's
right
whenever the word [ __ ] is spoken it is
always followed by the same question can
white people say [ __ ] and the correct
answer is not really
you have to check with your [ __ ]
consulate talk to your [ __ ]
representative and they will tell you
the [ __ ] rules where you are at that
particular time right Mac so we live in
a crazy time with dr. King and mr.
Mandela's dreams are coming true black
people and white people in Asians
Indians and everybody's hanging out
together and have interracial passes
it's unbelievable what's going on have a
bunch of white friends and all my white
friends have one black friend
[Applause]
but if you have an interracial Posse if
you are in an interracial person you
have to figure out you know what are the
rules of the integration possible
what mother dr. dre rules of your crew
that's right because you know what are
the dr. Dre rules what are the rules
when a dr. Dre song comes on the radio
or plays at a club what is the procedure
that goes into effect
cuz sometimes up with my white friends
and the dr. Dre song will come up and
there's a lot of [ __ ] in the dr. Dre
song and they want to enjoy it but they
can't really enjoy it around me so they
start taking out the [ __ ] or mumble
in the [ __ ] it is just a sad sight to
see it's just sad to see some white
person trying to do a Nikolas rendition
of a dr. Dre song it's just [ __ ]
depressing
and then trying to wrap the law without
saying [ __ ] and they're like creeping
down the back Street on knees I got you
my glock [ __ ] cuz I don't know what the
[ __ ] Sam
this attack like that and I've never hit
a cab but I
[Applause]
but I know enough today to lean into
that [ __ ] he's not here turn it down a
backstreet all knees I've got to my [ __ ]
[Applause]
since attack like that and I'd never
hesitate I put back cow say hey man
that's not even in the song
I got a little carried away so I run
there they should put it in they really
should ah don't worry white people get
your Dre on get your dry on get UJ on
get your Kayne on the side so look it's
okay it's got if it's gotta be in the
song it's gotta be in the song it's got
to be in the song so the quest to
remains to say can watch people say yeah
and that answers the same not really
oh there's some exceptions like [ __ ] me
harder [ __ ]
a lot of white women try not to laugh or
for the day's husbands right now nobody
knows what white people you've been very
good and keeping that [ __ ] of secret
amongst the samples I study white people
hello dad I'm right in the paper on you
not eating for school just to do it just
kissing who's doing this independent
research and spending my money so I'm
working so hard I follow you around
grocery stores they freak out
I just try to peek in the car they
always seem get away from my cart [ __ ]
what are you looking at chicken and
chips are over there you must be lost
these are vegetables I know what you
drink see how quiet I got grape juice
surprise [ __ ] you didn't know I
know about grape juice did you oh don't
play dumb with me there was a lot of
black people don't have the privilege of
knowing about grape juice because they
have great drink it's not the same
formula that you give ain't no vitamins
in that [ __ ] you might have plenty of
black friends over todd todd would you
care for a glass of grape juice [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is juice I want some grape
drink baby
oh it's purple I don't think I know what
a great drink is what I have some apple
juice if you want what the [ __ ] is juice
I want some apple drink scream
remember that commercial was sunny
delight when all the kids running from
outside playing and they all run to the
fridge all right I got some purple stuff
some Sunny D soon as a sunny day all the
kids oh yeah watch the black kid in the
back if you ever see that commercial
again look at that black kid be like I
want that purple stuff ice test drink
beta is drink they want
they will drink when all them vitamins
make our drink checkout water purple
that's the ingredients sugar water and
of course purple it's too [ __ ] much